- [Heavy breathing]
- [Growling]
MICHAEL GIACCHINO
Cut! That was pretty good.
♪♪
KEVIN FEIGE
You may know Michael
as an amazing composer.
But he also is a very
talented director.
MICHAEL GIACCHINO
Werewolf by Night.
This is something I've been wanting
to make since I was making movies
when I was a kid.
Hopefully it goes as smoothly as
those old Super 8 movies.
ANTHONY GIACCHINO
Mom, he's gonna be directing for Marvel.
Michael's wanted to do this
since he was a kid.
MICHAEL GIACCHINO
Directing this movie, it's really just
an extension of what I've always done.
To be able to make a Marvel
monster movie, I am so lucky.
[Laughing]
[Growl]
[Scream]
MICHAEL GIACCHINO
This is my life right now.
(A behind the scenes look at
Werewolf by Night.)
JOSEPHINE GIACCHINO
MCU?
ANTHONY GIACCHINO
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
JOSEPHINE GIACCHINO
Oh. Okay.